right
um
so i'd like to first thank the
organizers for inviting me to speak um
what i want to do during this hour is or
show you guys an application of tensors
okay so in particular i want to look at
application of secant varieties in
statistics and show that how
understanding the geometry geometry of
these c-cap varieties can give us a way
to make headway on a particular
statistical problem okay so there's many
applications
of tensors to statistics and so i'm just
going to go over one and so in
particular i'm going to talk about
mixture models and their connections to
secant varieties and a particular
application to evolutionary biology
so one of the things i want to throw
around a lot is
the word statistical model so let's
first define what we mean by a
statistical model
so our models are going to be discrete
and
when we say a statistical model is going
to be a subset of the probability
simplex so
a statistical model
which we're going to refer to as sort of
mathcal elm
is a subset
or i should say is
a collection
of probability distributions
and so i'm going to have to figure out
how low i can go here
um but we think about it as a subset of
basically
that n minus 1
dimensional simplex or what we call the
probability simplex and so i'm just
going to define this as
the set of all points
in
p to the n
right where all the entries are
uh
i'm sorry so this is going to be a point
in r to the n where all the entries are
real greater than zero and that may sum
up to one
this is the definition to be a discrete
probability distribution right and the
simplex is going to be the collection of
all those probability distributions when
my state space has size n and then our
model is going to be a subset of that so
the picture that you guys should always
have in mind
right
is
so if i'm in three dimensions what's the
difference between capital n and small n
did i write small n yet
yes you did oh i did this should be
capital n
and actually i sort of
i'm off by one two
okay so that's very good
all right thank you all right so this is
going to be our probability simplex and
then our model is some sort of subset of
that okay
so this might be our m
okay this is a set of all probability
distributions and that's our model and
in general our model is going to be a
semi-algebraic set
okay and we're going to work in the case
where we're going to think about this p
not as a vector but as a tensor okay so
i'm going to have
and m random variables so i'm going to
let x 1
to xm
do random variables
with
state spaces
c1
up to cm
okay so this is just right one two three
up to c one and i'm using that bracket
notation
and then we're going to think about
so p
is going to be an element of r to the c1
dot dot times r to the cm
okay so i'm thinking about it as a
as our ray
right which is c1 times
c2 dot dot dot times cm
and then p
i1
i2
up to im
is going to be the joint probability
of
for this distribution okay so this is
going to be the probability
this is going to be the probability that
x1 is equal to i1
x2 is equal to i2
etc
okay and so we're going to sort of think
about p
as a tensor and i'll call it a
probability tensor
and then we can ask all sorts of
questions like that so if i'm like in a
discrete setting one of the things i can
ask about is maximum likelihood
estimation and to figure out the maximum
likelihood degree under certain models
and so this is a problem that say jose
rodriguez looks at
so
we're going to look at it in a different
way what we're going to think about is
we have this model and we're going to
take the algebraic closure of the model
and the idea is that the geometric
information about the closure of our
model which is going to be algebraic
variety is going to give us
statistically relevant information
and we're going to use that information
okay and so
sorry the first example that we always
see
and
that you guys have seen a lot but not in
this setting is the independence model
um and so
i want to let x1 and x2 be random
variables
okay and so we say that x1
is independent of x2 so this is the
notation that i'm using for independence
um
if and only if
for all i and j
with i not equal to j
we have this relation so this is
something that you're going to remember
from when you first
stick took statistics right that
the
two random variables are independent if
and only if right their joint
distribution is a product of their
marginals and so let's write that out
so the probability that
x1 is equal to i and x2 is equal to
j
is equal to
the probability that x1 equals i
times the probability that x2 equals j
and i can rewrite this right so i have a
notation i have an indeterminate for
that so if i'm thinking about p as sort
of a tensor of unknowns
i can write this as
p i j
and then i'm going to use this
shorthand script for the marginals so
this is going to be where
i sum over all the j's
and here i sum over all the i's okay
and so now this gives us
a relationship that we might be familiar
with right
so basically
i can say
plus
this model the independence model
okay
is the set
all probability distributions
okay and in this case our probability
distribution is going to be a matrix
we're going to represent in terms of a
matrix so all probability distributions
that satisfy
write these binomial equations p i j
times p k l
minus p i l p k j
is equal to zero okay so we have these
binomial relationships that are defining
our model so what is this right we've
seen this before this is a segregated
variety okay
and so this is going to be sort of the
building block of what we're going to be
working with
okay
so
basically to sum this up right
if we take
the independence model and we close it
this is going to be the
set of rank 1 matrices
break rank one what c1
cross c2 matrices
okay
and we feel very some you know we feel
very familiar with this variety right if
we take the projectivization it's the
cigarette
okay and it's the product of p c one
minus one
times p
okay so now what we're gonna do is now
that we have a model we can sort of take
mixtures of models okay and so i'm going
to take these as my building blocks and
i'm going to combine them and then we're
going to see what
what happens
okay so
now let's introduce a mixture model
okay so we're going to let
m1 and m2
statistical models
and we're going to assume that they're
algebraic semi-algebraic sets
that's going to make everything work
very nicely for us
so the mixture
of f1 and m2
right i'm going to just take the set of
all convex combinations
of a probability distribution here and a
probability distribution here
so
it's going to look like this it'll look
like lambda p plus 1 minus lambda q
right such that p is in our first model
q is in our second model
and
lambda is between zero and one
so again this should give you
reminiscent of the sort of the things
that we've been talking about okay
um if we were
you know in sort of geometry world and
right this should remind you of the join
a little bit except the differences as
i'm taking a convex combination all
right this is something that you should
have in your head
um
and we can define mixtures
of a model with itself
okay and
just so we're all on the same page with
notation i might call the first mixture
model
of a model is just going to be itself
okay
and then the art mixture
is where i take the art minus minus one
mixture
with m
okay and then we can also write this out
explicitly
so the art art mixture of m
is going to be the set of all
probability distributions that rise as
the sum in this way
okay where i have a lambda i for all r
and this upper index is just going to
mean that i'm taking a problem
i have the
way to say that i'm taking the i
probability distribution
each of the p upper index eyes are in
our model
and lambda
is in the r minus one dimensional
simplex
all right and there's several of the
different canonical examples of mixture
models okay so i've written this out you
can hopefully you guys can all guess
where i'm going right i'm going to see
camp varieties
we'll get there um so there's a couple
of canonical examples of mixture models
in the literature okay so the first
example is if i wanted to take a mixture
of binomials and the way that you can
think about this is okay i'm a gambler
and i like to cheat and i have two coins
right i have a coin that's weighted
fairly and i have another coin that is
biased okay
and i might have them up my sleeve and
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take one of them out with probability
lambda lambda flip it four times and
then if i'm lucky maybe i get all heads
and i win a bunch of money okay so
that's their first canonical example of
a mixture model and that's the mixture
of two binomial distributions
there's a couple of other examples of
mixture models
so those of you who were here last week
on friday there were a couple of people
that talked about mixtures of gaussians
right that came that was a theme that
came up a lot um that's sort of outside
this context because we're working with
discrete models but there was another
model there was this topic model right i
don't know if you guys remember but this
tree
clone tree is going to come up again
you're sort of representing it like that
okay and that is actually related to the
type of mixture models that we're going
to be looking at
so our first example
of
a mixture model right is what if i take
the mixture of a bunch of independence
models
what happens
so example
so if we look at the mixture model
i'll take the earth mixture model of the
independence model and instead of write
instead of doing two random variables i
could have done more i could have done
three random variables or four et cetera
right they were just giving me a
different segregate
everyone agree with that
okay so if i take the mixture model of a
independence model this
way this is going to consist
of all probability distributions
or i've been calling them tensors right
probability tensors
a non-negative rank
less than or equal to r okay and we have
the non-negative right because
these are all
these are all probability distributions
all their entries are above zero okay
and so we can ask a bunch of questions
about these sort of mixture models and
these non-negative rank models and so
this is sort of work that kaya kubas
works on and elena robivo work on right
and in there they want to keep
keep this non-negativity okay and what
we're going to look at we're going to
take the algebraic closure and so we're
going to lose this non-negativity but i
do want to emphasize that there's a lot
of interesting geometric questions to be
asked just in this setting
okay and so we have this proposition
um and this
source language site for this is um
the green book on the lectures of
lectures on algebraic statistics by
dirten's
sullivan and strimfelds
but you guys can sort of as an exercise
prove this by yourself it's going to be
you know a two-line proof
so
if m
is a semi-algebraic set
then we have that the
art secant
of sort of the closure of the model the
risky closure of the model
is equal to if i take the earth mixture
from the model and then close it
okay so then that's what this is
basically telling me is this arth oh
where in my example
so if i take
the art
um mixture model here and i close it
right what am i gonna get is the rc camp
variety
okay
elizabeth do you know if i then
intersected those again with the simplex
i took the elevate closure and i
re-intersected with the simplex
did i get back the probability tensors i
furnished shaking his head no i don't
think you do i think something weird
happens and i think this is actually
sort of investigated further in sort of
the green book on the lectures on
algebraics but you can see that actually
that won't be the case
it could be that there's risky closing
false phase your model's not all space
that can happen a lot right
okay so in particular so if i take this
proposition and apply it to my example
right so in particular
i take
this mixture right which is sort of
my favorite example for this talk
secant
what c1 minus 1
2 minus one etc
okay and
what is this this is the set
of all
c1 dot ocm
tensors
of border rank
and
i sort of missed mike's talk earlier
yesterday i don't know if anyone got
into border rink but what happens is
so when we're dealing with matrices
right and we take the rank of a matrix
right if i look at all matrices all n by
n matrices with rank less than r right
that's an algebraically closed set but
when i go to tensors i look at all
tensors
with rank less than or equal to r that's
no longer algebraically closed okay and
just not
is the available number of rank 1
tensors that i can write it as
and so the main idea
or at least the idea for the application
that i'm going to show and sort of this
is a recurring theme in algebraic
statistics is that vanishing polynomials
on this closure of m which i'm going to
refer to as the model variety
i shouldn't even say can i always say
they give us statistically relevant
information okay
so i might be talking with a bunch of
statisticians and they're going to be
saying okay well you're taking the
algebraic closure of everything over the
complex field why are you doing that i'm
a statistician i only care about things
that you know are real and positive
right and we're going to say oh it's
okay this geometry is still going to
give us information that we can use
and so the application that i want to
look at comes from evolutionary biology
and is going to be modeling phylogenetic
trees
okay
and so in this application right we have
dna
from a bunch of different species
so we're going to assume that's aligned
in some sort of way
we're going to make a couple of
assumptions on our data
the first one of course being that is
aligned
the second one that we have site
independence
and what we want to do is taking these
dna sequences we want okay
so our goal
is
given
aligned
dna sequences
and species
right find the tree
that best describes
their ancestral history
maybe if i was fitting this data i might
find
like this
where
gorilla
and so
this problem right
this is this problem is called
phylogenetic rate tree reconstruction
and there's several ways that you can do
this okay there's distance based methods
as well but we're going to look at sort
of the statistical way to do this in the
statistical way in phylogenetic tree
reconstruction you're going to put a
statistical model on the process okay
and then we're going to look at it from
this model
so do you know ahead of time how many
nodes you want to have on the tree yes
you do so that's going to be your number
of living living species that you have
data from will be your number of leaves
yeah so that's number of leaves oh
in the general case no
um
but you might make some assumptions like
the assumption that we're going to make
is that we're in a trivalent tree right
so that
each of the interior nodes only has
degree three
okay so you can make some simplifying
assumptions like that
depending on what assumptions you make
your methods may be different
and so what we're going to do right we
have like
some tree
we assume that we actually know the tree
in this
when i'm describing the model i'm
describing the model with the tree okay
and so
and each tree will give rise to his own
model
okay so we're going to assume
evolution proceeds
along a tree
according to a markov process
okay and so basically these these
interior knows there are hidden knowns
they correspond to extinct species or
species that we can't measure and the
leaves are going to correspond to
accident or living notes i mean living
species and then we're assuming that
evolution is proceeding along and then
there's so according on each of these
edges i have a matrix associated to it
and that's my probability trans
transition matrix okay and that's going
to be the probability right this is
going to tell me the probability that if
i observe
for example a
here right that i'm going to observe at
a here and etc okay so if i'm
modeling this in regards to like the
four
um nucleic uh the four nucleotides right
this would be a four by four matrix
and so one of the ways so what we want
to do is we have all this data and we
want to infer the tree topology
so there's one way to do this that uses
algebraic methods
um
and
let me describe this a little bit
so each of these models right
i have a statistical model and some
subset of the probability simplex
is a semi-algebraic set i can take this
closure right and it forms a variety
okay and i get a variety for each of
these trees right so if i want to do
model selection and in model selection i
mean select the tree you know infer the
tree topology what can i do well i can
take my data which is going to be this
which is the frequency and you know i'm
going to have some set of how often i
observe a's and so forth and that's
going to give me a data point okay it's
not going to lie on any of those
varieties a priori right because there's
some sort of noise in the data
what what i can do is i can find the
variety that that data point is closest
to okay and then once i find the variety
that that data point is closest to
that's going to tell me my tree topology
okay so that's the underlying idea
so these algebraic methods
they're basically going to use
the defining ideal
is the model variety
and
in this literature this would be called
the phylogenetic ideal
and these methods were first proposed in
like 1987
and so there was um they were proposed
in two papers in independently in the
first by kevin der and felsenstein and
the other by lake and when they first
did these methods right what they did
was they had sort of this you know
they didn't have the whole generating
set but they had the linear polynomials
from the generator set so they tried
this method just using the linear
polynomials right the polynomials of
degree one and when they did that they
found that it didn't work very well okay
and i believe that's what lake had done
and so in 2006 marco castanellas and
jesus fernandez sanchez tried this again
right but using the full set of
invariances and these are for some
particular models where the environments
are very well understood and easy to
write down
and they found that actually it
performed as well as other methods in um
in a variety of cases and so that gave
hope that there might actually be um
i mean that gave hope that these
algebraic methods may actually work very
well
okay so now right i sort of started off
this talk talking about secant varieties
now i just find a model which is not
necessarily a secret variety but let's
get back to that
let me and let me explain the
relationship now
so the
um depending on sort of the structure
that you put on these transition
matrices you'll get different models and
so the model that we're going to look at
is the general markov model
okay and i'm sorry going to illustrate
this through example
all right so let's do the r state
abbreviate this gmm
on the claw tree
k13 so i
thankfully hero sort of introduced this
notation for me right so this is a
bipartite graph where i have one node
and then three
okay so our tree is going to look like
this
okay and then remember for each edge
right i have a matrix
and each of these matrices right they
have this form so if i write out the
matrix m1
i'm not going to write out the whole
matrix but the i t entry is going to
look like this it's going to look like
the probability that x1 is equal to i
given that y is equal to j
because one is coming from the fact that
i'm looking at this number one matrix
okay so that's what the i shape
i j entry looks like
and then y
is a hidden variable
distribution
pi
now we have r state so it'll be pi 1 up
to pi r
okay so now what we're going to do is
we're going to write the
probability so p j k l so the
probability that x one equals j
um
x two equals k and x three equals
l now we'll see what we get
so now this should sort of remind you of
sort of these latent variable models
that people were drawing last week
that they didn't really get into so now
you guys are
sort of fleshing out the details of this
model right
okay
so then
we have the following so if i were to
write p
j k l
right that's the problem
um
this is the probability that x1 is equal
to j x2 is equal to k x3 is equal to l
i have to sum over all possible states
of this hidden variable
okay
and so i'm going to get something like
this
right
so
so for example if y is in state 1
right then the probability that i will
say c
j k l
is going to look like the probability
that
or let's say if y is in state i okay
there's the probability that y is in
state i
times the probability
that i move
from
i to j
okay
times the probability that
i see
k and the second
k for the second random variable given
that i started at i
and then etc
and so
all right so this looks like something
right that we know and love okay this
looks like our a tensor with rank less
than or equal to r
okay
so the probability tensor
is an r by r
by r matrix
oh sorry not matrix
maybe on that okay
okay is in r by r by r tensor with rank
listener equal to r
okay and so in fact
this general markov model is our mixture
model okay
so in fact
the general markov model
on a13
for our states
is the same
family of distributions
with three independent random variables
and where each of the random variables
can take one of our states
okay so we just
right we started off with this
independence model we looked at mixture
models and now i'm showing okay in this
application right what we're dealing
with are these mixture models
okay so
so there's these a couple of nice
theorems that says that no matter what
our tree is if we want to understand the
phylogenetic invariants right which are
basically the generating set the
defining ideal
of this model variety that all we need
to understand are these claw trees okay
and so in fact if i'm just looking at
trivalent trees or bifurcating trees
then all i need to understand
is this leaf claw tree and i i know all
my invariants okay and so this is
actually a theorem due to almond and
rhodes and then it was generalized by
drysma and cutler
so
okay so if we
let t
be a trivalent tree
and variance
or t okay and so when i say invariance
rate you're thinking about generating
polynomials
can be attained
from the invariance
or the general markov model
a13
and miners
of matrices
obtained by tree splits
okay and i just want to show an example
of how you get these miners of matrices
for tree splits because i believe is one
of the problems on there
so what do you mean by invariant
so
by in variances of poor choice of words
but it's become sort of canonical nature
so the invariants are going to be the
gen the generating polynomials of our
ideal
okay so
here's an interesting question okay so
if i just have two states right
if each of my random variables can have
two states
then what are my invariants what am i
defining
right if i just have two states then i'm
looking at the set of two by two by two
tensors with rank less than or equal to
two
all right and we know something about
that right
we know that the generic rank of two by
two by two tensors is two right
okay so that means that fills up the
whole space and so i'm not going to get
any invariance from this claude tree so
i'm just going to get these in variances
from these minors of matrices that come
from these splits
okay
so let's see an example of how and this
gives you a nice example because then
all you're caring about is the tree
splits and you get to do these fun
things with the flattenings
so
is our example
but also a theorem
okay so if we let t
get a trivalent heat try failing
trays
with end leaves
okay
the model ideal
for the general markov model on
me
with binary states
okay that means everything my y and all
my x's can only be zeros or ones
as generating set
i take the union over
all balance splits
and so i'll explain what a valid split
is a second
and then i take the three by three
minors
the flattening that i get
according to that split
i'll do an example
so now in order to understand so now
these phylogenetic and variants right
they're just three by three minors
okay so let me draw a tree here
so let's say i have this tree
bifurcating
i believe this tree came up before my
talk too
so a balance split
is a bipartition
of the leaves
such that the induced trees
do not intersect
okay so a valid split here
okay so what would be a valid split
there
i take one two
and three four
and then a not valid
right because if i look at the trees
induced by one two
i get this one and the tree induced by
three four is going to be that one so
not valid view would be like one three
and two four
so the induced tree
yeah you take the leaves and then you go
up and you find their most common
parrots
how about the split one
um and that would be a
that would be a valid split
but okay so that would be a valid split
um
and but we won't get any generators from
that split
okay and then when we take the
flattening
in regards to the split so what i mean
by that right is so if i take this split
one two
let's just do an example
okay i'm going to sort of unfold my
tensor until it's a matrix and what i
want to do
simple way that i can think about this
is okay i write down all the entries
that can be for
one two right so
in the one two entries of p
i j k l right i can have 0 0
0 1 1 0
1 1 and then i do the same things
do the same thing for the columns and
then so this entry right would be p000
this one would be p001
okay
and so that's sort of an interesting
example with the flat means and like i
said they come up in the problem set
okay so
this is when we have binary states the
other relative um
so there's two sort of
um
there's two cases that
are relevant when we're thinking about
biology they're when all the random
variables have two states or when all
the random variables have four states
okay and so we can ask about this
question right so
we have this nice theorem right that
says okay we can understand these
phylogenetic invariants as long as i
understand this claw tree okay and so we
can ask this question
um
what are the invariants when we're
looking at the general markov model when
every state
when every random variable has four
states
okay so
so what about the general markov model
on k13
when each random variable
has four states
okay and so that is
what are the generators
the ideal
defining hope
the fourth secant variety of p3 cross p3
so these had sort of come up i think in
landsberg's class as well
um
so this question is actually to find the
generators of this ideal i think it's
still open as far as i know okay so it's
still open but we do have a set
theoretic description of this ideal okay
okay and so
i list a long list of people here
because this is sort of like a
culmination of a bunch of work sort of
got pieced off piece
bit by bit
but there is a that set theoretical
description of this thinking variety
okay
so
okay and so
i can't write out the polynomials for
you but i can tell you the degrees of
the polynomials okay so the set of
tensors
these are in 64 variables
and so like some of these um
some of these polynomials like the
degree six polynomials i believe they
have like on the order of 500 and 900
terms
okay so these are big
all right
so the set of tensors of
oh i
okay so the set of four by four
by four tensors
of border rank
almost four
is cut out
by polynomials
of degree five
six
and nine 9. so i sort of want to just
take
you know one moment to sort of talk
about this because i think this is a
nice confluence of symbolic and
numerical methods okay
um
so this is actually so i
this
this problem sort of became popular by
elizabeth altman right who's i think
proposed it in 2007 and said if anyone
can come up with these this um idea the
generators of this ideal i'll go out to
my backyard and i'll catch you a salmon
right and this is how it's become known
as the salmon conjecture
and so there were a couple the original
conjecture said that this set was cut
out by polynomials of degree five and
nine
and today
degree five and nine and so the degree
five equations um
first sort of come from straws in and
then they are independently um refound
by almond and rhodes
and then landsburg and mound will have
this two paper from 2004 where they
found these degree six equations okay
and that they knew that these had to be
then i in that die ideal
okay so that brings us here
and then schmill friedland he was able
to prove that
basically
this variety was defined set
theoretically by polynomials of degree
five nine and he couldn't use the six
but he was able to use sixteen okay so
we're getting even closer right but
there's still this question right we
knew that the degree six polynomials had
to be there and then in fact so there's
this work by dan bates and luke owning
right who actually show that
actually
set theoretically it is degree five
degree six and during e9 and they use
bertini to show this okay
and so then
you know
you're almost there right and then we
just put the rest of it together and we
were able to take sir freelance result
right with the degree 16 and replace
those with the degree six okay
and so this sort of
so even though we don't have an ideal
theoretic
description
of
this phylogenetic ideal we actually have
enough polynomials that if we actually
wanted to use them in practice that we
could now the problem is is how do you
use these in practice right i just told
you that there are polynomials that have
like 500 and 900 terms they're
ridiculous right and so one of these
questions and one of the things that i'm
bringing you as a plea right
is that we have all this nice theory
right we have this next theory in
algebraic statistics and algebraic
geometry um and there's applications out
there and so how can we start thinking
about how to bridge the divide between
the theory and the applications right
um
and
yeah and so i think this is sort of the
right community to do that in so i've
shown you one application of tensors and
statistics but there's definitely plenty
more okay now
in statistics people like to reject some
hypotheses yes
how do you reject the philogenetic tree
you have the polynomial you have the
data okay you have a criterion for the
data not to fit
right so this is actually one of the
hard parts for applying these algebraic
methods to um these phylogenetic trees
so there's another project that i'm
working on with biochemical reaction
networks it's the same thing you have
models that are defined by sets of
polynomials and in that case right your
data you know if you're assuming
gaussian noise on the data you know that
the
your closest point right how you want to
define closest is with the l2 norm and
you have a statistical reasoning for
choosing that in this case this data
right is
it's sort of an estimate of the
distribution right and so i actually
don't know how i wanted to find closest
point to the variety and so this was
actually
one of the first questions that needs to
be asked
so actually when marta castanellis had
did
marta and jesus did their experience
experiments how they defined close to
the variety was they just plugged in
their data points into the polynomials
and then they took the abs you know the
sum of the absolute value of all all the
values that they got right and this
actually performed very well and i know
that um
um
i want to say joe rusenko
and assumed dan bates brent davis had
had looked at this in another context in
these pilot you know fitting these
phylogenetic trees and they used the
orthogonal projection right where i'm
taking closest to point meaning i'm
minimizing the distance
from the variety and that wasn't working
any better than the way that marta and
jesus did it so so this is this is a
fundamental question so
rejecting in this case we don't know how
to reject the same setup in other cases
like with the biochemical reaction
networks we can we can describe
explicitly when you reject but in this
case
maybe i can make a remark ideally we
would like to compute a p-value but
we're very powerful
first of all we like to use one of these
equations as a test statistic or the
absolute value of the test statistic but
to even but we need to know the
distribution of the test statistic over
the space of data to even set up a
p-value calculation so in principle
there's a methodology but we don't know
how to do the math exactly
exactly
can you explain better which kind of
equation marta casanellas use the
because visual analysis was before the
equation uh
yes
were found and also right this was so
they there's some assumptions that you
can make on those um matrices so in this
general markov model setting the
transition probability matrices they can
have any entries and that makes it the
most general model but if i put some
symmetries on them on the matrices right
so these
uh no the transition probability
matrices on
so
right
i have a matrix on each of these edges
right that tells me the probability of
trans
if i see you know a here what's the
probability i see it here well i can
make some simplifying assumptions on
these matrices right i can have like all
alphas along the diagonal and betas
elsewhere
and when i make those then it's much
easier and we understand the equations
better
and so i don't know what particular
model that they looked at but they
looked at one of these where you
where it's not the full general it's not
the general setting as this one it's a
restricted study
equation it should be possible to make
the same analysis with the general
matrix or any mistake
uh repeat your question again so it
should be possible to repeat the
analysis with the general four times
four yes you you should be able to but
um
yes but yeah and all but there's the
problem of okay even evaluating these
polynomials is going to take time
you're asking to find the closest
in 64-dimensional space this is not
trivial even if you knew all of the
equations and everything and even if the
equations were reasonably nice which
these might not be this is still a very
difficult thing to do even uh yeah but
but remember greg great um they in marta
and jesus they didn't use the closest
point they just evaluated the
polynomials
and saw how close that was to zero
so maybe in that method you could
definitely with closest point right then
i'm doing this minimization problem
right where i have a yeah
this is a very unwieldy minimization
problem that i wouldn't be able to solve
um even i think with numerical methods
so
isn't it possible to just use
open set and so just take code mention
many random
linear combinations of these polynomials
yeah you're probably right probability
one we're still on that variety i guess
uh if we're just an open set that
contains a variety of the same direction
you're right and actually um this
actually brings up another point right
because i'm being a little bit tricky
here because i'm saying that we actually
need the full set of mammarians but
actually
margaret jesus actually showed you don't
actually need the whole set of
invariants um you just need what are
called the edge invariants okay
so that probably answers georgio's
question they use these degree five
equations
so this time does let's begin